all right okay so let's start with we're
talking about music today which is fun
and awesome but first let me give you a
brief whirlwind
reminder of what we did last time we
talked about hearing in general and
speech in particular
and we started as usual with
computational theory thinking about what
is the problem of audition
and what is sound that's the first step
of that sound is pressure waves
traveling through the air
and the cool thing about hearing is that
we extract lots of information from this
very very simple signal of pressure
waves arriving at the ear we use it to
recognize sounds to
localize sounds to figure out what
things are made of and to understand
events around us and all kinds of things
and these problems are a major
computational challenge
and in particular they are ill-posed
that means that
the available information doesn't give
you a unique solution if you consider
the computational problem narrowly and
that's true for separating sound sources
so if you have two sound sources at once
to say two people speaking or a person
speaking and a lot of background noise
that's known as the cocktail party
problem those sounds add on top of each
other and there's no way to pull them
apart without bringing in other
information knowledge about the world or
knowledge about the nature of voices or
speaking or who's speaking or you need
something else or else it's imposed that
is not solvable just from the basic
input
another case of an old post problem in
audition is the case of reverb so the
sound that i'm making right now that's
coming out my mouth is bouncing off the
walls and is arriving at your ears over
each little piece of sound that i make
is arriving at different latencies after
i say it as it travels different paths
bouncing around the room and there's not
too much reverb in here so it's not
uh it's not that noticeable but if we
did this in a cathedral you'd hear all
these um echoes
okay and so that makes another ill post
problem because all of those different
sounds are added on top of themselves
diminished in volume over time and you
get the sum of all of those and you have
to pull it apart and figure out what
that sound is
so both problems are solved by using
knowledge of the real world in the case
of reverb it's actual implicit knowledge
that you all have that you didn't know
you have about the physics of reverb
because if we play you sounds with the
wrong physics of reverb you won't be
able to deal with reverb and that says
it's implicit knowledge in your head
which is pretty cool that you use to
constrain the opposed problem
we talked about speech phonemes are
sounds that distinguish two different
words in a language like make and bake
those are two different sounds that make
the difference between two words each
speech sound is um each possible speech
sound is not a phoneme in every language
of the world
languages have some subset of the space
of possible phonemes that distinguish
words in their in their language
phonemes include vowels that have these
stacked harmonics of um in the in the
spectrogram and consonants which are the
quick transitions in the vertical
stripes in the spectrogram leading into
the harmonic stacks of vowels
we talked about the problem of talker
variability that a given phoneme or word
sounds very different looks very
different in the spectrogram if spoken
by two different people
and conversely the same person speaking
two different words looks very different
in the spectrogram and so that means
that the identity of the speaker and the
identity of the word being said are kind
of all mushed up together and that means
that if you want to recognize the voice
independent of what's being said
or recognize the word independent of
who's saying it you have a big
computational challenge a classic
invariance problem yeah ben
i don't mean to hold this up i just want
to be sure that i'm understanding this
consonants are
the difference between consonants and
vowels
like are valves just harmonic like
connective elements between like
consonants and our consonants
like percussive or are they actual
like i i just didn't understand that
yeah so in in the spectrogram
those those i don't i didn't put that on
the slide here but those horizontal red
stripes in the slides that i showed you
last time those in the spectrogram those
are bands of energy at different
frequencies that are sustained over a
chunk of time and those are typical of
vowels
right or singing or music also um and
those harmonic sounds that have pitch
and so vowels have those kind of
sustained chunks that look like this in
the spectrogram and then they're these
weird vertical stripes and transitions
in and out of the vowels that are the
consonants
just
the air is just flowing through and
you're filtering it somehow by
positioning your vocal tract certainly
and constantly starting to close off
that air or or restrict it at some point
um so like
s's and s you're not pushing all the way
off but you're really constricting the
vocal tract and a lot of other constants
you're actually fully closing
okay and then we talked a bit about the
brain basis and i pointed out that the
neuroanatomy of sound processing the
subcortical neuroanatomy is much more
complicated than the subcortical
neuroanatomy of
vision envision you have one stop in the
lgn and then you go up to cortex coming
up from the retina in audition you have
many stops between the cochlea where you
pick up sounds
in in the inner ear
and auditory cortex um some of those
stops are shown up here and we didn't
discuss them
um so then we talked about primary
auditory cortex that's on the top of the
temporal lobes like right in there
medially you went in
um and it has this tonatopic property
and that is a map of frequency space
with this kind of systematic high low
high mapping of frequency space
that you can see here high low high like
that this is the top of the temporal
lobe right there
okay
um and i pointed out that in animals and
in
one recent mri study the response
properties of primary auditory cortex
are well modeled by these fairly simple
linear filters known as spectrotemporal
receptive fields or stiffs shown here
okay so this they're kind of simple
acoustic properties of a given band of
frequencies rising or falling at
different rates
okay
okay so today
we're going to talk about music
and this is also an important moment in
the course because up to now we've been
talking about functions that are mostly
shared with animals speech is kind of on
the cusp i was going to make this
point before speech and that it's
actually muddy because lots of animals
are really good at speech perception you
know chinchillas can distinguish ba from
paw go figure anyway um so that they can
perceive speech but obviously they don't
use it in the same way but music is most
definitely uniquely human
and so most of the things we'll be
talking about from here on out are
things about the human brain in
particular
and i think these are the coolest things
in human cognitive neuroscience because
they tell us something about who we are
as human beings
but they're also the hardest ones to
study
why is that
no animal models
right and i'm always lamenting about the
shortcomings of each of the methods in
human cognitive neuroscience and we have
lots of them and they complement each
other but there's a whole host of things
that none of those methods are good for
and so now we're really out on thin ice
trying to understand these things uh
with a weaker set of methods where we
can't go back and validate them with
animal models and that's just life
that's what we do
okay so now let's back up for a second
and consider why am i allocating a whole
lecture for such a fluffy frivolous
topic as music
and i would say
that's because it's not fluffy it's
actually fundamental
and it's fundamental in the sense that
music is both uniquely human no other
animal has anything remotely like human
music and it's also universally human
that is every human culture that's been
studied has some kind of music so music
is really an essential part of what it
means to be a human being it's really at
the core of humanity and that alone
makes it interesting
but further question
birdsong doesn't count no birdsong
doesn't count in all kinds of ways
um uh one it doesn't have anywhere near
the flexibility and variability there's
like narrow domains in which you know
each each um
uh
zebra finch male zebra finch makes a
slightly different version of the call
but within an extremely narrow range
uh there's actually a brain imaging
study that looks in a brain imaging in
birds
songbirds
and asks do they have reward um
reward uh brain region responses to
music
um and the answer is yes in some cases
like like do they enjoy it right is that
part of that you know the answer is yes
but only when the significance of the
bird song is something that's relevant
to them like there's a potential mate
right here then they like it
but they don't like it just for the
sound and that makes it very different
from humans and there are other
differences as well
okay
okay
so it's further really important to us
humans in a whole bunch of ways one we
have been doing it for a very long time
um and so for example the archaeological
record shows these 40 000 year old bone
flutes
that you can see from the structure of
the fruit of flute make
particular sets of
of possible pitches
and further most people have thought
about this have argued that singing
probably goes back much farther than the
bone flutes after all you don't have to
make anything to do it you can just sing
right
some have even speculated that singing
evolved before language okay it's just
speculation but that's possible in any
case it goes way back evolutionarily
it also arises early in development so
very young infants are extremely
interested in music
they're sensitive to beat and melody
independent of pitch we'll talk more
about that a little bit
and finally if you're not impressed with
any of those arguments people spend a
lot of money on music and if that's your
index of importance it's really
important
last year 43 billion in sales okay
so i'd say it's not a frivolous topic
it's a fundamental topic it's near the
core of what it means to be a human
being
and all of this raises a really obvious
question
why do we create and like music in the
first place what is it for
right
and this is a puzzle that
people have thought about for
at least centuries probably millennia
and this includes all kinds of major
thinkers like darwin
who said
as neither the enjoyment nor the
capacity of producing musical notes are
faculties of the least direct use to man
in reference to his ordinary habits of
life they must be ranked among the most
mysterious with which he is endowed okay
so
darwin is sort of implicitly assuming
here that music is an evolved capacity
right it's not something that we just
learn and that cultures invent if they
feel like it or don't feel like it
but it's actually evolved
and shaped by natural selection and that
means there must be some function that
natural selection was acting on that was
relevant to survival okay
so
um people have speculated about what
that function might be
those who think that music is an evolved
function including darwin he speculated
that it's for sexual selection
and his writing is so beautiful i won't
paraphrase it he says
it appears probable that the progenitors
of man either the males or females or
both sexes before acquiring the power of
expressing their mutual love in
articulate language
endeavored to charm each other with
musical notes and rhythm
okay so that's darwin speculation just a
speculation but a lovely one
also note that he threw away this
radical idea in here before acquiring
the power to express their mutual love
in articulate language so he's think
he's speculating that that um music came
before language again all speculation
but interesting speculation
more recently
up the street
there's a bunch of people who've been
thinking about this a lot
uh and sam mayor at harvard has been
arguing that the function of music and
song in particular which he thinks is
really the the fundamental basic kind of
native form of of music um has an
evolutionary role in managing parent
offspring conflict and that's something
that many evolutionary theorists have
written about the genetic interests of a
parent and an offspring are highly
overlapping but not completely
overlapping the parent has other
offspring to take care of besides this
one right here that one right there
wants 100 of the parents effort therein
lies the conflict
um and so
mayors proposed that
that infant directed song
arose in this kind of arms race between
the somewhat competing interests of the
parent and the offspring and it kind of
manages this need the infant has to know
the parent is there
with the fact that the parent has other
needs i guess idea they can sing while
attending to other
other
offspring
and on and on so there's other kinds of
speculations like this but importantly
this is not the only kind of view
it's not necessarily the case that music
is an evolved capacity so others have
argued that it's not
so steve pinker
also up the street has argued that music
is auditory cheesecake
an exquisite confection crafted to
tickle the sensitive spots of at least
six of our mental faculties
if advantage from our species the rest
of our lifestyle would be virtually
unchanged
i think that might say a little more
about steve pinker than it does about
music
nonetheless it's a possible view okay
um what he's saying is that music is not
an evolutionary adaptation at all
but an alternate use of neural machinery
that evolved for some other function and
then once you have this neural machinery
what the hell you can invent cultural
forms and use it to do other things like
music okay
and the most obvious kind of
neural machinery that you might co-opt
for that function would be neural
machinery for speech or neural machinery
for language
okay which as i argued briefly last time
are not the same thing one is the
auditory perception of speech sounds and
the other is the understanding of
linguistic meaning
okay so the nice thing about this is
finally after all this entertaining but
like you know kind of speculative stuff
we have an empirical question
this is something we can ask empirically
does music actually use the same
machinery
as speech or language or does it not
okay some of the rest of these
speculations are very hard to test so
stay tuned we'll get back to that
shortly
but first um let's let's step back and
think okay if music is an evolved
capacity
it should be
innate in some sense at least
genetically specified right because
that's what evolution does is that
it you know natural selection acts on
the um on the genome to uh to produce
things that are genetically specified
and it should be present in all human
societies right since the branching out
of human societies is very recent in
human evolution so is it
well
his music is an innate
um
so let's suppose suppose we found
specialized machinery in the brain in
adults
for music and we showed really
definitively it's really really really
specialized for music
would that prove innateness
no why not
bingo thank you very good
yup
exactly so this is something that many
many people are confused about including
colleagues of mine most of the popular
scientific press
just because there's a specialized bit
of brain that does x doesn't mean x is
an eight it could be learned and the
clearest example of that is the visual
word form area everybody get that
okay
okay so we've got to try something else
what if we find sensitivity to music in
some very music particular way
in newborns
okay now that will get closer
but here's the problem
fetuses can hear pretty well in the womb
and if the mom is singing or even if
there's music in the ambient room some
of that sound gets into the womb
so that means
that even if you show sensitivity to
music even in some very particular way
in a newborn
it's not a really tight argument that it
wasn't impart learned okay
so this is a real challenge
it may just be impossible to answer i'm
not sure i don't know how i don't know
what method could actually answer this
but at the very least it's really
difficult and nobody's nailed it
so we can backtrack and ask the
related not quite as definitive question
but okay how early developing is it so
often developmental psychologists kind
of take this hedge it's like we can't
exactly establish definitive innateness
but if things are really there very
early and develop very fast that's a
suggestion that at least the system is
designed to pick it up quickly so even
if there's a role for experience there's
some things that are picked up really
fast and some things that aren't
and so how quickly is it picked up
so turns out there's a bunch of studies
that have looked at this
and young infants are in fact highly
attuned to music
they're sensitive to pitch
and to rhythm
and in one charming study they took two
to three day old infants who were
sleeping
put eeg electrodes on them
and played them
um they wanted to test beat induction
which is you know when you hear a
rhythmic beat you get entrained to the
beat and you know when the next beat is
right and that's true even if it's not
just a single pulse so they played these
infants sounds like this
oh but the audio's not on
now it's going to blast everyone
all right hang on
oh it is playing turn up more okay
i didn't want to deafen people
okay
it's not but that's supposed to work
right
it has worked before
let's just check your system settings
really quickly
because i can hear you from my system
yeah it's weird okay
wait if i can hear you from my system
you are then it is going out yeah
um oh somebody
okay ah
okay try it one more time okay here we
go
did you hear that glitch let me do it
again
let's take it back here
everybody hear the hiccup in the in the
beat
okay
so that's what these guys tested they
played rhythms like that
to two to three day old infants
um
and um
oh now it's working okay great okay
anyway so here's what they find with
their erps
this is um the onset of that little
hiccup
the time when that beat was supposed to
happen and didn't the missing beat right
there and this is an erp response
happening about 200 milliseconds later
for that kind of missing but expected
beat
um and and um let's see this is a
standard where the beat keeps going now
you might say well of course they're
different one has a beat there and one
doesn't they're acoustically different
so they have a control condition which
has a beat but a different preceding uh
context so where that beat is is not um
i'm sorry where it has a missing beat
but that's expected by the previous
context okay so that's just evidence
that um even young infants have some
sense of
of beat
so moving a little later by five to six
months
infants can recognize a familiar melody
even if it's shifted in pitch from the
version that they learned okay and
that's really cool because that means
they use relative to pitch not absolute
pitch and that's something that you know
adults do in music we're very good at
that but no animal can do that you can
train animals to do various things like
recognize a particular pair of sounds or
even a few sounds a few pitches but if
you transpose it they don't recognize
that yeah
yes hang on to that thought it takes
more work to show that it's music per se
rather than just rhythm and pitch we'd
have to say what we meant by rhythm if
we load a lot enough into the idea of
rhythm then it's like most of music
right there but you know we might say
just even beat how about that right
and actually already this study already
is not just an even beat because it has
more context than that that that is for
example the the beats
uh in this erp infant study
were not um emphasized louder the
infants have to be able to pick out what
the beat is from that complex sound it's
not it's not automatically there in the
acoustic signal as the louder
onset sound okay
okay
five month old infants if you play them
a melody for one or two weeks so they
get really familiar with it and learn it
and then you don't play it again and you
come back eight months later they
remember it
okay so music is really salient to
infants
on the other hand newborn infants
appreciation of music is not uh um
what is that not doing there
oh yeah
that's right um so they don't prefer um
consonants over dissonance
right
um
and um
they're insensitive to key
yeah
so um and and and they um
they detect
timing changes in rhythms
um whether they are timing changes that
are typical in the kind of music they've
heard
or typical and a more foreign kind of
music okay
and so
a really nice study that shows this
is that in western music it's really
common to have the most most western
music has isochronous beat so you can
see that over here here's an isochronous
beat those are even temporal intervals
and there's a whole note here and then
half notes and they're all uh multiples
of each other just holes and halves
with the beat happening every four
notes okay
um non-isochronous beat has this funny
business where there's a whole note then
and a half note making up just um
uh three
what do you call those things they're
not beats what are they called
sorry three notes i guess but it's not
even notes because it's whatever i don't
know what the terminology is but anyway
this sound here followed by four
okay this is non-isochronous rhythm
those are really common
in uh balkan music um where they are
they do all kinds of crazy things like
you know 8 22 or something like that i
mean like really really crazy musical
meters they're awesome i love them uh
but they're very other like you know if
you
grew up in a you know western society
when you first hear balkan rhythms or
it's very hard to copy them
but
six-month-old infants get rhythms
equally well if there's isochronous or
non-isochronous
okay
um by 12 months they can only get
automatically like immediately perceive
and appreciate um rhythms uh that are
familiar from their cultural exposure
that is isochronous if they're from a
western society or
a non-isochronous if they're from a
balkan country
uh well so there's a whole bunch of
studies i'm just summarizing here that
is they're sensitive to violations right
by all kinds of measures of you know
little whatever behavioral thing you can
get out of a five-month-old whether it's
how much they're kicking their legs or
how much often it's obvious how hard
they're sucking on a pacifier is another
measure so you just see can they detect
changes in a stimulus or violations by
any of those measures or you could do it
with the earpiece okay
okay
so brief exposure
to a previously unfamiliar rhythm is
enough for a 12 month old
to uh to appreciate the relevant
distinctions in that rhythm
but not for adults
okay so if you haven't heard
non-isochronous balkan rhythms
until now
and you try dancing to them good luck to
you
okay
you can probably get it eventually but
it will take you a long time
yeah
so does this sound familiar
perceptual narrowing right so we keep
encountering this we encountered this
with face recognition
um with um same versus other
races same versus other species you see
it in face recognition
we encountered it with phoneme
perception the phonemes remember infants
newborn infants can distinguish all the
phonemes of the world's languages even
those exotic cliques that i played last
time from southern african languages
and you guys can't distinguish all those
clicks
now so that's perceptual narrowing and
it makes sense of course because the
reason we have perceptual narrowing is
you don't you want to have invariance
you want to appreciate the sameness of
things across transformations and if
your uh speech culture or your music
culture is telling you these two things
this variation doesn't count you want to
throw away that difference and treat
them as the same and then once you do
that you can't make that discrimination
anymore
right
okay
so on this question we started with is
music in evolve capacity if so it should
be innate and we haven't really answered
that question maybe but as i said it's
really hard
and maybe ultimately unanswerable but
certainly it's early developing
what about this other question is it
present in all human societies
okay
uh well i said before briefly that it is
oh yeah sorry we have to back up and say
okay what to answer this question we
have to say what is music okay
to answer whether it's present in all
societies and this has been a real
problem right because uh music is
notoriously hard to define
and many people have made a point of
stretching the definition of music
including the ridiculous and hilarious
john
cage
okay so this is his 1960 tv
a tape appearance machine which will
provide much of the resets the machine
so we can know where it is which will
provide much of the background uh also
he works with a stopwatch the reason he
does this is because these sounds are in
no sense accidental in their in their
secrets they each must fall
mathematically at a precise part so he
watches him watch as he works he takes
it seriously i think it's interesting if
you are amused you may laugh uh if you
like it you may buy the recording
john cage and
walmart
so
anyway it goes on like that
i guess it was a little edgier in 1959
than it is now
um but he's making a point
he's making a point of what the hell is
music
right
and he's saying i can call this music if
i want
and everybody's enjoying it
anyway
okay
so you can watch the youtube video if
you want it's quite entertaining
um
despite this kind of nihilistic view
that anything could count as music there
are some things we can say
first thing i'd say is if you want to
study music
you know one of your first things you
run into is oh what's going to count you
run into this problem here but actually
i think that doesn't need to be so
paralyzing as it feels at first you can
just take the most canonical forms where
all of your subjects will agree that
this is music and this isn't and then
someday you can study the edge cases
later but you don't need to agonize
about them in order to get off the
ground and study it
further we can ask what is music
cross-culturally
right i keep forgetting my next point
okay
and let me make another point is that
music is not just about a set of
acoustic properties
you may think of music as just an
auditory thing a solitary experience
because a lot of the time it's like that
but remember that that's a very recent
recent cultural invention
right and throughout most of human
evolution
music has been a fundamentally social
phenomenon
more like this
you know experienced in groups of people
as a kind of deeply social
communicative interactive kind of
enterprise or even if not in a large
group music is very social in this sense
here there's a whole bunch of cool
studies about the role of song
in infants and how infants use song to
glean information about their social
environment
and the point is just music is extremely
social it's not just defined by its
acoustic properties
okay but in addition
uh we can ask okay let's look across
the um cultures of the world and ask
are there universals of music is there
anything in common
across all the different kinds of music
that people
experience in different cultures for
example are there always discrete
pitches or always isochronous beats i
already showed you there aren't always
acronis beads and this is nice because
it's an empirical question
there's a really cool paper from a few
years ago where they took recordings of
music from all over the world all those
colored dots
and they asked
what are the properties that are present
in
in
most of those musics and how prevalent
are they and what they found is there's
no single property of music that's
present in all of those cultures but
there's many that are present in most
and there are a lot of regularities
so this is a huge table from their um
paper where they list many different
possible
universals and what you see is the
relevant column is this one here and the
white is the percent of those 304
cultures that they looked at that have
that property in their music okay so
these top ones are very prevalent just
not quite universal because there's a
couple of cases that don't happen
okay so
um so one of the most common ones is
idea that melodies are made up made from
a limited set of discrete pitches seven
or fewer
and that those pitches are arranged in
some kind of scale
with unequal intervals between the notes
okay so that's as close to a universal
of music as you can get although you can
see from that little teeny black snip
that it's not quite perfectly universal
uh and the second thing is that most
music
has some kind of regular pulse right
either an isochronous beat or even the
non-isochronous ones
have different subdivisions with
different numbers of beats so that
there's a systematic rhythmic pattern
okay so there's
something kind of like melody and
something kind of like rhythm in almost
all the world's musics
they did find some pretty weird ones
one i can't resist playing for you this
is from papua new guinea
so as they say the closest thing to an
absolute universal was song containing
discreet pitches or regular rhythmic
patterns or both
which implied to almost the entire
sample however music examples from papua
new guinea
contain combinations of
friction blocks swung slats ribbon reeds
and moaning voices i don't know what
those things are either but i'll play
them for you in a second
uh that contained neither discrete
pitches
nor an isochronous beat okay here we go
[Music]
okay pretty wild huh
okay so uh maybe wilder arguably than
john cage but anyway so there are some
like pretty um pretty um remote edges to
the concept of of music
okay
um i mentioned before uh the case of
consonants and dissonance and that
infants don't prefer one over the other
um in fact this this uh links to a
really cool recent study from josh
mcdermott's lab and so the question he
asked is why do we like consonant sounds
like this
whoops i'm gonna play
here we go
kind of nice right
but we're not so
hot about this
right everybody get that intuition okay
so what's up with that
um so many people have hypothesized for
a long time that that difference is
based in biology or there even it's like
a physical uh analog of it beats and
stuff like that
but actually uh it's a it's an empirical
question and so one way to ask that
question is to
go to a culture that's had minimal
exposure to western music all of which
really prefers consonants over
dissonance yes kylie
oh yeah yeah i'm sorry totally different
word consonants
c-e has no relationship to consonant
consonants
as distinguished from vowels okay a
consonant and a vowel those are two
different kinds of phonemes
here consonants is that difference
between those two sounds i just played
right and it has to do with the um the
precise intervals of those
of those harmonics in the harmonic stack
okay
all right
okay so what mcdermott and his
co-workers did
is go to go to a bolivian culture
in the rain forest in a very remote
location
to test these people here the chimane
and the chimane black televisions and
have very little access to
recorded music and radio
their village doesn't have electricity
or tap water you can't get there by road
and you have to get there by canoe
so that's what mcdermott and his team
did they went down there to visit the
chimane
and
and what they found they played them
consonant sounds and dissonant sounds
and with a translator and spent a lot of
time making sure that they really
understood the difference between
liking and not liking and they tested
their understanding of what it means to
like something or not like it and all
kinds of other ways and the upshot is
the chimani do not have a present a
preference for consonants over
dissonance
okay
so it's not a cultural universal
and that's consistent with the idea that
it's not a preference in infants either
okay
okay so this is something specific to
western music
okay
so that's kind of introduction to what
you know some stuff about what music is
and what its variability is and the fact
that it's
its presence is universal and there are
many very common properties across the
world's musics and it develops early
okay
uh so let's ask is music a separate
capacity in the mind and brain all right
so let's start with the classic way this
has been asked for many decades and
that's to study patients with brain
damage
and it turns out there is such a thing
as amusia the loss of music ability
after brain damage okay
um or um yeah and so there are both
sides of this there are people who have
impaired ability to recognize melodies
without impaired speech perception and
there's the opposite people who have
impaired speech recognition without
impaired melody recognition
okay
so that is of course a double
dissociation sort of it's a little mucky
in there i'm just if you state the words
simply like that if you look in detail
there's some muck as there often is
so let's look in a little more detail at
these two cases the most interesting
ones who
who seem to have
problems with auditory tunes but not
with words or other familiar sounds
okay
so here is a horizontal slice this is an
old study so it's a cat scan showing you
something's up with the anterior
temporal lobes in this patient
and this was true of these two
classic patients cn and gl both of them
were very bad at recognizing melodies
okay even highly familiar melodies you
know happy birthday and stuff like that
they don't recognize
um they mostly have intact rhythm
perception and this is a this is a core
question we'll come back to it's a
complicated non-resolved situation but
these guys had intact rhythm perception
and relatively intact language and
speech perception
okay
um
however
upon further testing it becomes clear
that these guys have a more general
problem with pitch perception
okay
even if it's not
in the context of music okay so this is
a question that i asked all of you guys
to think about for in the opposite
direction in your assignment um for
sunday night right when i asked you
whether those um
electrodes in in the brains of epilepsy
patients that are sensitive to music too
sorry to speech porosity to the
intonation contour in speech i asked you
whether you whether you thought they
would also be sensitive to the
intonation contour in melodies and most
of you said yes it's pitch pitch contour
must be
well it's a perfectly reasonable
speculation but not necessarily maybe we
have special pitch contour processing
for speech and different pitch contour
processing for music right it's possible
it's an empirical question was there a
question back there a second ago okay
um okay
so um
maybe this is about uh pitch for both
speech and music uh not music per se
okay
um and so there are there are more
detailed studies of patients with
congenital amnesia and just like the
case with
acquired prosopagnosia versus congenital
prosopagnosia whether you get it from
brain damage as an adult or whether
you've just always had it your whole
life and nobody knows exactly why and
there's no evidence of any brain damage
the same thing happens with a congenital
amnesia
so something like four percent of the
population
is you know they might say they're tone
deaf but just to tell you what that
means it can be really quite extreme
they can just completely fail to
recognize familiar melodies that anyone
else could recognize okay
they may be unable to detect really
obvious wrong notes in a canonical
melody
they're just really bad at all of this
and further they don't have whopping
obvious problems with speech perception
so at first
was thought that speech perception was
fine
but if you look closer it looks like
actually there is even outside of music
there is a finer grained deficit in a
pitch contour
perception that shows up um even in
speech okay it's what i mentioned before
so we can ask this in the of sort of the
reverse case of the ones you considered
now we have people who have this problem
with pitch contour perception in music
are they going to have a problem also
with pitch contour perception in speech
okay so that's what this
study looked at
so they played sounds like this and you
have to listen carefully there will be
sentences spoken
and you have to see if they're identical
or different so listen carefully
she looks like anne
she looks like anne
many people thought that was different
good you got it okay so one is a
statement and one is a it's not quite
it's sort of a question
it's in a sort of british accent it's a
little harder to detect but different
intonation contour okay so that's what
the um that's what the tang at all paper
was talking about is that distinction
right okay so we can then ask that
subtle distinction are people with
congenital amusia impaired at that right
so if it's specific to music they
shouldn't be but if it's any intonation
contour they should be
oh yeah i'll play the other ones okay so
well okay
so they are in fact impaired this is
accuracy here the controls are way up
there the a musics are down there
so they are impaired at this kind of
pitch contour perception thing even in
the context of music
okay i'm sorry i said that wrong even in
the context of speech
okay so it's not just about music
okay and in the controls they have
sounds like this which they
which are just
just tones
okay got that it's the same kind of
thing but not speech and you see a
similar
deficit in the a musics compared to the
controls
and then they have a nonsense speech
version
same deal the music the a musics are
impaired
compared to the controls
so that shows that the deficit for these
guys is not specific to music per se but
it seems to be a
pitch um contour problem in general that
extends to speech
we'll get there
sort of it would have been nice if the
tang at all paper had included some
musical contour stuff they didn't but
i'll show you some of our data shortly
that gets close to this
okay
okay
so all of that suggests that this amuseo
is really more about pitch than speech
i'm sorry what's the matter with me it's
really more about pitch than music
right
okay
but
the reading that i signed today for
today
is a very new
uh twist in this evolving story right so
this used to be a nice clean lecture
with a simple conclusion and now all of
a sudden i ran across that paper it's
like wow okay
that might not be quite the case
so what do what did you guys get from
the reading in what way does that kind
of slightly complicate the story here
yeah quietly
yeah what they found is that a lot of a
musics not all of them
also have problems with rhythm
and that isn't consistent with the idea
that a musia is just about pitch
whether in speech speech or
music
right
and that says okay many a musics also
have problems with rhythm
okay
um so there's a standard battery that
people use that asks
dana help me what does the standard
battery ask people
kinds of things that people without
musical training answer fine although
there's quite a range i'm at the way
bottom end of dana's scale when she
gives these
reasons
just that there's prior evidence on and
the stuff i showed you and a whole bunch
of other studies seem to suggest that
amusia both in acquired brain damage and
congenital amusia seem to be really when
you drill down more of a problem with
pitch per se even pitch in speech
and so then it seems like if it's about
pitch
why would it also go along with rhythm
right
and so when it goes along with rhythm
that sounds starts to sound more like
this is something about music right it's
not you know it gums up the story yeah
talia right
when it comes to like natural speech
when you have like some kind of
incarnation like
you know pitch differences when you
emphasize like especially in terms of
like a question
aren't there also some kind of like
rhythmic differences yeah
so how do you like kind of separate
you just have to do a lot of work to try
to separate those out right and so the
paper i signed to you guys did some of
that work and there's still room to
quibble but they they did you know there
was experiment two and they tried to
deal with exactly that kind of thing of
saying okay let's try to make sure that
um
that well actually the controls that
they were doing slightly different they
were trying to make sure that the
um
the beat tasks didn't require pitch
right so it's very it's very very tricky
to pull these things apart which is yeah
so like the beat tasks like make sense
but i'm just like in the first one like
even from the paper that was like a sign
on sunday
like i don't know so you're saying that
it's totally possible to kind of
separate algorithmic differences from
like when you're just changing
it's really really difficult it's really
difficult dana's trying to do
experiments that do this right now and
she's invented some delightful and crazy
stimuli that try to have one and not the
other it's very tricky
right you can have
rhythm without pitch change that you can
totally do right
it's really hard or impossible to have a
melodic contour without some beat or
other
we have some crazy stimuli that sort of
do that but they're pretty crazy right
so anyway these are very tricky things
to pull apart um and and this is all
right right at the cutting edge these
things have not been
cleanly separated okay i'm running out
of time so
do you have a quick question
okay sorry about that
um okay
so conclusions for the patient
literature there's suggestive evidence
for specialization for music
but no really clear dissociations
music deficits are frequently but not
always associated with just more general
pitch deficits
um and all of this is complicated
because there's lots of possible
components of music right
you know when there's pitch deficits is
it is it pitch or relative pitch
interval key melody meter all these
things are different facets of music
uh and so it's really not resolved
exactly what's going on here right it's
kind of encouraging that there's a space
in there but not resolved
okay so let's go on to functional mri
and we're going to run out of time so
let me just take a moment to figure out
how i'm going to do this
um
what the hell am i going to do here
okay well i
hate to well okay
okay you guys are gonna tell me at 1205.
yeah okay i'll see maybe we can get off
of this okay so here's a really charming
study from a few years ago
that tried to ask whether there are
systematic brain regions that are
engaged in processing music and they
used a really fun
um perceptual illusion okay that you're
going to hear i'm going to play a speech
clip
and it's just going to part of it's
going to be repeated many times and just
listen to it and and think about what it
sounds like
to own and eat one
there was a cold drizzle of rain the
atmosphere was
murky there was a cold drizzle there was
a cold drizzle
there was a cold drizzle
there was a cold drizzle
there was a cold drizzle
there was a cold drizzle
what happened
yeah
what happened
you started to hear a melody
and you didn't hear the melody the first
time he said it was just normal speech
right speech has this kind of intonation
contour and he's speaking with an
intonation contour but then somehow when
you keep hearing it it turns into a
melody
okay so it turns out that doesn't work
for all speech clips in fact it's really
hard to find speech clips for for which
it works but there are some
but you know everyone has that
experience or most people do and that
gives us a really nice lever because we
can take that same acoustic sound when
you hear it as speech and when you hear
it as melody and we can ask are there
brain regions that respond
differentially it's sort of analogous to
upright versus inverted faces although
it's even better it's the exact same
sound clip that's construed one way at
first and another way afterwards
okay everybody get that
um
okay so that's what these guys did they
used a standard block design they just
listened to those
sounds and they just looked in the brain
to see what bits respond more
after the sound starts getting perceived
as music than before when it was being
heard as speech and they got a bunch of
blobs in the brain it's a bit of a mess
but they got some stuff
um
and um and so that's sort of fun
um but it's also kind of ambiguous we
still don't know if this is about
some kind of pitch processing which is
becomes more salient
you hear it as abstract pitch or whether
it's really about melodic contour or
what so that's a cool study but i think
it doesn't really nail what's going on
so another angle at this is to ask
whether music recruits neural machinery
for language okay so let me
say why this has been such a pervasive
question in the field so there's a lot
of people who've pointed out for you
know 30 years or probably more there are
many kind of deep commonalities between
language and music so they're both
distinctively or uniquely human they're
natively auditory right that is we can
read language but that's very recent
really language is all about hearing
evolutionarily
they unfold over time
and they have complex hierarchical
structure
okay so you can parse a sentence in
various ways and there are all kinds of
people who've come up with ways to have
hierarchical parsings of pieces of music
as well
so there's kind of a lot of deep
connections between language and music
and so many people have hypothesized
that they use common brain machinery
okay and they're in fact many reports
um from neuroimaging that argue that in
fact they do use common machinery like
we found overlapping activation in broke
areas broca's area for people listening
to
music and speech
okay
however
those studies are all group analyses now
if i forget if i've gone on my tirade in
here about group analyses have i done
the group analysis tirade in here you'll
get more of it later i'll do a brief
version now and you'll get more later
here's a problem group analysis is you
take you scan 12 subjects you align
their brains as best you can
and you do an analysis that goes across
them okay
and you find some blob say
here yeah be there uh for listening to
sentences versus listening to non-word
strings okay that's a standard finding
then you do it again for listening to
melodies versus listening to scrambled
melodies
and you find the blob overlaps
and you say hey common neural machinery
for sentence understanding and for music
perception
okay
now that's that's an interesting
question to ask it's close to the right
way to do it but there's a fundamental
problem
and that is you can find an overlap in a
group analysis even if no single subject
shows that overlap at all
why because those regions vary in their
exact location and if you mush across a
whole bunch of individuals you're
essentially blurring your activation
pattern
okay
and so all of the prior studies
until a few years ago had been group
analyses and they found overlap and who
the hell knows if there was actually
overlapping activation within individual
subjects which there would have to be if
it's common machinery or if they're just
nearby and you muck them up with a group
analysis and they look like they're on
top of each other
okay if you didn't quite get that we'll
be coming back to that point for now all
you need to know is many people ask this
question and the methods were close but
problematic
um but luckily however at federenko did
this experiment right a few years ago
so here's ev and here's what she did
she funky functionally identified
language regions in each subject
individually okay we'll talk more about
exactly how you do that you listen to
sentences versus non-word strings you
find a systematic set of brain regions
that you can identify in each individual
that look like this here is in three
subjects those red bits are the bits
that respond more when you
listen to a sentence versus listen to
non-word strings or read sentences
versus non-word strings
then what she could do is she said now
that i found those exact regions each
subject i can ask of those exact regions
how do they respond to music versus
scrambled music okay so she played stuff
like this
okay so nice canonical you know nothing
crazy weird we're not going with the new
guinea in music and asking edgy
questions we're just saying something
everybody agrees that's music versus you
scramble it and it sounds like this
okay it's actually the same notes yeah i
know i know a lot of people that go
that's cool that's really edgy yeah it
is but you know to most people it's it's
not canonical music okay
okay and so what i've found is that none
of those language regions responded more
to the intact than scrambled music
okay
so language regions are not interested
in music and we'll talk more about that
next week or the week after
then she did the opposite she identified
brain regions
here in a group analysis just to show
you where they are anterior in the
temporal lobes that respond more to
intact than scrambled music okay she
identified those in each subject and
measured the response of those regions
to language
sentences and non-word strings
and each of those regions
respond exactly the same to sentences
and non-word strings
so basically
the
language regions are not interested in
music and the music regions are not
interested in language and therein we
have a
thank you
exactly
okay
um so
um music is not using machinery for
language okay that was one of the
hypotheses we started with no it's not
okay
um
so that's true at least for high-level
language processing that computes the
meaning of a sentence
um but what about speech perception
remember last time i made this
distinction between the sounds like ba
and pa
um which have a whole set of
computational challenges just under you
know just perceiving those sounds which
is quite different than knowing the
meaning of a sentence okay
so what about speech perception or in
fact any other aspect of hearing
okay so what i'm going to try to do
is briefly tell you about one of our
experiments i'm sorry i try not to turn
this whole course into stuff we've done
in my lab but it's one of my favorite
ever and it's kind of a cool different
um
way to go at this question from the
other mri experiments we've talked about
before
so the background is okay let's step
back what's the overall organization
organization of auditory cortex and when
we did this experiment five or six years
ago not a whole lot was known basically
everybody agrees whoops my i put the
wrong slide in here everybody agrees
that primary auditory cortex is right
there with that high low high frequency
thing we talked about from there but
from there on out and you know in the
last couple years
there's an agreement about speech
selective cortex that i showed you
briefly last time and other people have
seen that
but there's kind of no lots of
hypotheses and no agreement with
anything else and and no real evidence
for really music selective cortex okay
so but there's a problem with all the
prior work where you sit around and make
a hypothesis and say oh let's see
are we going to get a higher response to
say intact versus scrambled music
or you know faces versus objects or
whatever right
all of those are scientists making up
hypotheses and then testing them
and there's nothing wrong with that
that's what scientists are supposed to
do invent hypotheses and then make good
designs and go test them
but the problem with that is
we can only discover things that we can
think to test
what if deep facts about mind and brain
are things that nobody would think up in
the first place
and so that's where we can get real
power from what are known as data-driven
studies
where you collect a boatload of data and
then use some fancy math and say tell me
what the structure is in this data not
is this hypothesis that i love true in
these data
and i'll do anything to pull it out if i
can see it in there find evidence for it
in there but yeah exactly but if we
collect a whole bunch of data and do
some math and see what the structure is
what do we see
okay so that's what we did in this study
i'm going to speed up to try to give you
the the gist here okay so we as sam
norman hagner here and josh mcdermott
and so we scanned people while they were
hearing stuff like this
we first collected
the 165 categories of sounds that people
hear most commonly this is classic
cocktail party effect you guys are doing
you have to separate me speaking from
all this crazy weird changing background
um
and so anyway we scan people listening
to these sounds which broadly sample
auditory experience right and so we
collected sounds people hear most often
and that they can recognize from a two
second clip okay enough already
oh yeah
just to wake everyone up okay
so we scan them listening to those 165
sounds broad sample of auditory
experience
then from each voxel in the brain
we measure the exact magnitude of
response of that voxel to each of the
165 sounds and we get a vector like this
everybody with me that's one voxel right
there another voxel another oxel okay
we do this in all of kind of greater
suburban auditory cortex that is not
just primary cortex but all the stuff
around it that might even remotely you
know that responds in any systematic way
to auditory stimulated grab the whole
damn thing okay
so you do that in ten subjects
you have a big matrix like this a
thousand voxels in each subject eleven
thousand voxels across the top 165
sounds that's our data
okay
so each column
um is the response
of one voxel in one person's brain to
each of the 165 sounds everybody got it
okay now we have this lovely matrix
which is basically all the data we care
about from this whole experiment then we
throw away all the labels
poof it's just a matrix
and then we do some math which
essentially says
let's boil down the structure in this
matrix and discover its fundamental
components
that math happens to be a variant of
independent component analysis that
means anything to you if it doesn't
don't worry about it the gist is we're
doing math to say what's the structure
in here and we're doing it without any
labels so this analysis doesn't even
know where the voxels are or which of
your 10 subjects that voxel came from it
doesn't know which sound is which and so
it's very hypothesis neutral it's a way
to say show me structure
with almost no kind of prior biases just
show me the structure okay so everybody
get how that's kind of a totally
different and kind of thing to do from
everything we've talked about so far
okay
so that's what we did i'm going to skip
the math and the modeling assumptions
not really that complicated but we're
going to run out of time
so very hypothesis neutral and what we
find is
six components
account for most of the replicable
variants in that whole matrix okay i'll
tell you what a component is in a second
do you have a question
it doesn't with pca you assume
orthogonal axes with ica you don't
assume orthogonal and axes and so it's
very very similar to pca
and it starts out as pca and then it
does some more rigmarole yeah it's the
same idea
like basically tell me the main
dimensions of variation
uh yes they are sparse and that is one
of the assumptions you use it's actually
there there isn't only one one way to
factorize a matrix it's an imposed
problem so you need to make some
assumptions but you can and that's one
of the ones we made but you can test
them okay
okay
so what we find is six components
account for most of the data
and
four of those
reflected acoustic properties of the
stimuli okay
one
was high for all the sounds with lots of
low frequencies another was high for all
the sounds with high frequencies what is
that
sorry speak up
they're sensitive to frequency but where
is that in the brain that you've already
heard about
primary auditory cortex as a tonatopic
map so this is awesome because if you go
invent some crazy math and you apply it
to your data and you discover something
you know to be true that's very
reassuring right the math isn't just
inventing crazy stuff it's discovering
stuff we already know to be true
that's known in more biological parts of
the field as a positive control invent a
new method make sure it can discover the
stuff you know to be true okay so check
check okay
um all right
but then it discovered some other stuff
and i'm just going to tell you about two
of them
so here's one so i was just loose about
what a component is a component is
a magnitude of response for each of the
165 sounds
okay
and a separate distribution in the brain
which i'll show you in a moment in a
moment so here's one of those components
and if we we've taken the 165 sounds and
added basic category labels on them we
put them on mechanical turk and people
told us which category they belong to
so that enables us to look at this kind
of mysterious thing and average within a
category
so this is this component
and if you look at it you see
that it's really high
for
english speech and foreign speech that
our subjects don't understand
and then oh what's that intermediate
thing
oh that's music with vocals
it has a kind of speech
okay so and way down here that's
non-speech vocalizations stuff like
laughing and crying and sighing so
there's a voice but no speech content
okay
so that's a speech component
and what's and as i mentioned this had
been seen before in the last few years
so it wasn't completely new but what's
cool about this is this just emerged
spontaneously from this very broad
screen we didn't go and say hey can we
find a speech selective region of cortex
if we try really hard oh yeah we
validate our path this is like let's
sample auditory experience and wow there
it is yeah
we put them on turk and had people say
what category they fit into yeah
absolutely absolutely this is a first
pass and one hopes to go deeper and
deeper like if we could separate
um you know
uh
uh oh different aspects of speech
consonants and vowels fricatives
whatever there could be much more to be
done yeah i get asked
oh boy okay
uh okay and when do i have to give them
the quiz
it's shortish they don't need a full 10
minutes
is what is it seven questions
eight eight minutes
okay
make me stop definitively at 12 18. okay
so that's cool
um
um it's not exactly new but it's a
really nice way to rediscover things
that we uh thought to be true okay
um all right
then there's component six
that popped out
okay what is component six well if we
average within a category
instrumental music and music with vocals
and everything else is really low
we didn't go looking for this
boom music selectivity
that's pretty amazing never really been
seen before
okay people have looked and they've made
some kind of sort of smoke and mirrors
like not really like this is the first
time it was seen and it just popped out
of the data and that says that it's not
just something you can find if you try
really hard and go fishing for it it's
actually a significant part of the
variance in this whole response i'm
going to skip everything except
clarification questions now because i'm
sort of it's complicated sorry that's a
lot it's a long answer okay so this
really looks like it's music okay and so
now
um i was vague about what a component is
but it's both that response profile and
it's a set of weights in the brain so if
you project this one back in the brain
you get this band of speech selective
cortex right below primary auditory
cortex like that
and if you project the music stuff back
in the brain
you get a patch as sort of an answer to
your question you get a patch up in
front of primary auditory cortex and a
patch behind
okay
um
and um okay so here we have a double
dissociation of speech selectivity and
music selectivity in the brain
okay so music doesn't just use
mechanisms for speech as many people
have proposed it's not true right
okay
so
when you see dramatic data like this a
natural reaction is to say like really
get out come on like music specificity
like what
okay so very briefly dana has just
replicated this in a new sample of
subjects it does not matter if those
subjects have have musical training like
students from berkeley school who spend
like six hours a day practicing
versus people who have essentially zero
music lessons ever in their life
you get those components in both groups
maybe slightly stronger in the trained
musicians we're not quite sure yet but
in any case it is totally present in
people with zero musical training that
doesn't mean it's innate because people
without musical training have musical
experience but no explicit training okay
skip all of this
here is her replication boom boom it's
there with and without training
okay
um i'm going to skip all this you can
read it on the slides if i lost you in
here because i want to show you
something else okay that music
selectivity
was not evident
if you just do a direct contrast in the
same data take all the music conditions
all the non-music conditions you get
kind of a blurry mess it's not strong
you have to do the math to siphon it out
and that's okay
but i like to see things in the raw data
and so probably what that means is the
music is overlapping with other things
in the brain and so the direct contrast
doesn't work well the math can pull them
apart but wouldn't it be nice to see
them separately and so we've been doing
intracranial recordings from patients
with electrodes in their brain and i'll
just show you a few
very cool responses okay so this is a
single electrode in a single patient
these are the 165 sounds same ones this
is the time course and this is a speech
selective electrode it responds to
native and foreign music those are the
two green ones
uh sorry native and foreign speech and
it responds to music with vocals in pink
everybody see how that's a speech
selective electrode okay so there's
loads of those but we also found these
here is a single electrode look at these
are um each
row is a single stimulus here's a
histogram of responses to all the music
with vocals music without vocals
much stronger than to anything else you
might be saying well what about those
things let's look at what those things
are oh
even the violations aren't really
violations whistling humming computer
jingle ringtone those are sort of musicy
right
so that is an extremely music selective
individual electrode in a single
subject's brain
no fancy math that might have invented
it somehow it's just there right in the
raw data okay
further and here's the time course you
can see the time course of music with
instruments music with vocals everything
else
really selective
okay
so this is the strongest evidence yet
for music specificity in the human brain
but there's one more cool thing that
came out of this
analysis
and that is we found some electrodes
that are not just selected for music but
selective for vocal music selective for
song
and that's really amazing because as i
started off at the beginning many people
have said that song is a kind of native
form of music the first one to evolve
and all that kind of stuff
and so we did all the controls it's not
the low-level stuff
and
there's lots of open questions
we started with this puzzle
of of how did uh how did music evolve if
indeed it did evolve and we made a
little bit of progress
it's not it doesn't share
machinery with speech and language
if it's auditory cheesecake as pinker
said
it's auditory cheesecake that not only
uses machinery that evolve for something
else but changes it throughout
development and makes it very selective
okay
these guys speculated that song is
special maybe it is
and sexual selection who knows we have
no data
you